The Joe Rogan Experience so what do you
think of this Jon Jones cereal gone
fight
honestly I think it's a
it's a tougher fight than Francis really
I do I think that Cyril got his movement
his footwork he's so good with his front
leg and for Jon Jones who when remember
when he came back from OSP he looks so
stiff and that was a time off and
putting a lot of muscle on he just
looked like a slower version of himself
so now this time it's a longer uh time
off and you're coming back with way more
weight on and you're going against one
of like the faster heavyweights in the
more smoother heavyweights instead of
young guy you were you know he lands
that Hard Punch I could do it but I
could just shoot under that Hard Punch
and guide you I mean uh zero gone you
have to watch the kicks watch the
footwork cut him off yeah the thing is
the Cyril gone was out grappled by
Francis when Francis had a bad knee
francis's knee was [ __ ] up and Francis
out grappled him and beat him handily
with his grappling yeah you know I
talked to Eric nixic and he said
francis's grappling is on a totally
different level than he used to be
before and he's so big and so strong
yeah you know he's in Camp with blagoy
uh even off yeah and he said he was just
holding him down doing whatever he wants
to him I'm like that is really
impressive because lagoy beat Fedor in
combat [ __ ] he's a monster he's a
monster he's the one guy like stabbed
right yeah in the heart yeah he's yeah
one time I saw him at uh you know he's
under Ali and we Ali had like a media
day for his Fighters and black boy like
comes up to me and like I make Pick 3 uh
every fight you know like Circle
fighters who I think he's gonna win I'll
post it on my Instagram and he like came
up to me and he like showed up he's like
you didn't pick me my last fight and I
was like I was like what you know I was
like dude I don't even think I don't
even know you Fighters even really pay
attention he's like I was like dude now
I started realizing that these guys are
like watching it but uh of course they
watch yeah I was like this guy's crazy
but I was like hey I gotta pick him
every single time he goes wow
that's like nuts but yeah I always talk
to Eric next to Eric next is one of
those coaches that he's like my brother
I'll call him after hey they're giving
me this guy what do you think about it
and he would always tell me like Francis
is France is one of those heavyweights
that loves to wrestle like you know
wrestling practice Strikers they don't
show up they don't they hate to be in
that grind it's a different type of
grind they said France is there all the
time he loves to be in there I mean
especially after that steepe fight the
first eBay fight he learned like that's
where his Achilles heel is is grappling
and that also you can't take everybody
out like sometimes like not in that
fight at least steepe just weathered the
storm somehow or another yeah and you
have to have the gas tank and you have
to have the grappling to survive all
those other exchanges but that was at
his moment remember when he was just
knocking everybody out and he had like
two minutes of fight time yeah then all
of a sudden you fight a guy oh dang it's
past the second round well it's also
like we talked about with Hamza when
Hamza went after Kevin Holland if you
get out of that round how much do you
have left yeah he got out of the round
Stipe made it out of the round and then
Steepy started dominating but that
second fight man Francis is takedown
defense he looked good patient Francis
that's what DC was saying patient
Francis is scary Francis yeah that's why
I'm mad yeah I'm mad because I feel like
we were deprived of one of the great
fights in MMA one of the most compelling
fights in MMA does it mean I'm not
interested in Cyril gone and Jon Jones
I'm very interested in that fight I'm
very for all the things you listed also
for Cyril God's performance against tied
to ivassa it's like God damn zero gone
and Cyril gone does a lot of [ __ ] that's
very unusual like first of all he stands
totally sideways and he does like a
twisting kick with his front leg to
throw a front kick you know yeah very
weird yes like he stands totally
sideways and he like twists his leg in
he doesn't stick it up and stab it
Forward he like twists it and go in yeah
you never did that well Taekwondo it's a
twisting kick yeah yeah it's called a
twisting kit okay yeah
so no that's him throwing side kicks
yeah spinning heel kick he he throws
this kick off the front leg if you go to
tie to ivassa
um the one he was Landing to that front
to the body yeah dude he's so tough Ty's
so tough that was a crazy ass fight and
that was a perfect fight to like
Showcase with Cyril guns capable of
because his his movement the fluidity of
his combinations and I mean a guy moves
like a middleweight he's 240 plus pounds
this was a great ass fight so he stands
sideways and he throws this front kick
when he gets distance he throws this
front kick off the sideways stance and
he turns his body
oh there's that kick to the body those
those round kicks oh this is the
finishing point oh yeah
very very interesting man watching the
two there it is yeah yeah see how he
throws it and he throws it off of both
sides with the front leg
he's the most agile in the the like
probably the most technical of all the
heavyweight Strikers
Cyril's very well-rounded when it comes
to his striking
he's so smooth yeah so and he's like
intelligent like he understands the
distance all right that's the knee this
is not kick distance very interesting
fight so for John it's going to be can
John take him down Ken John like how
does John perform at heavyweight can
John close the distance is he is fast
what is the three years off like is he
hungrier and even better because he's
fired up and he you know like y'all must
have forgot he's got that mindset he
usually does too right remember he was
always that guy that would want to beat
you at your own game oh you're arrested
I'll Russia you're a striker I'll strike
with you yeah so well he comes out there
thinking
zero gone you're a smooth Striker I'll
smooth you I don't know it's also a
first fight in heavyweight we really
don't know how he's gonna respond when
he gets hit by a big heavyweight
we don't know anything yeah and it's
years and it's also John is older now
you know
honestly a lot of partying yeah John
parties you know I don't know what he's
been doing maybe he's been living clean
over the last few years I don't know
what's up with uh sahudo now and yeah
maybe that that's a who don't mind so
we'll help him too so I like that I like
cerudo's mindset I like that fight ready
Camp I think what Henry brings to the
table is very unique his mindset is
really incredible and you know I talked
to Mighty Mouse about it I had Mighty
Mouse on and uh Demetrius was saying
that like he's so meticulous in his
training and how he prepares and plans
for things yeah like his everything is
like very very focused I was thought uh
Dan ige he was telling me how he went
down there and he was he's like I never
talked to anybody with kind of like the
war mindset as him it's like he sees it
as like a chess match he breaks it down
in that type of uh way it's not like
I'll just go out there see red whatever
happens happens he does this this and
this even with uh I said I had uh
breakfast of the months before the Sean
Brady fight and he was like let's watch
a little tape on him let's let me look
up what he what he does and just like
watching one tape of Sean ready oh well
he stands like this I think you should
do this this low kick will be perfect
right here but uh just seeing how he
breaks down how he talks to people it
just tells me that being a coach and
being at his gym he'll get deeper and
deeper and deeper into those little
aspects of the fight that a lot of
people don't really care about or look
at a lot of I know a lot of Fighters
that they'll never even watch tape of
somebody they're gonna fight they'll
never they're just going there with the
mindset if I'm in shape and I'm on my
bus I'm gonna win yeah I think he's one
of the great coaches out there I think
for us a Hobbies probably I mean he's
one of my all-time favorites it's not my
favorite but I think there's just a few
guys like that like Henry sahudo you
know that are just like their next level
coaches they just have this mindset it's
just that's the most important thing I
feel like it's not all about toughness
and right I've had coaches that tell me
that oh well this guy never fought
before why are you going to think that
he's a good coach but
you don't need to be a fighter or that
some people are just better at
understanding and breaking down fights
in general than having to go in there
and fight some people some people can
fight some of the great coaches like
think about guys like Teddy Atlas wasn't
known as a great boxer amazing coach
yeah you know like there's Emmanuel
Stewart wasn't known as a great boxer
but amazing coach one of the greatest
coaches ever there's there's quite a few
guys like that yeah I mean Eric Nixon my
coach Mike Valley never fall before he's
the same way and like I said it's like
some people are better at teaching some
people are better at breaking down film
and seeing other guys weaknesses like I
know what Nixon was telling me that he
would he used to be a football player
and he would like to like bring that
mindset that gameplay mindset of what's
the weakness if I know these guys are
good at the past well we're gonna play
past defense and then Fighters don't
think like that for me when I fought
Damian Maya my goal is to stand a strike
with you I'm not going to Grapple with
Damian Maya we're not fighting Wonder
Boy I'm not gonna strike with Wonder Boy
I'm gonna take him down right when I'm
fighting these guys a certain way
I'm switching it up each time is John in
Phoenix now is he training down there he
was uh I know he was down there he said
he was down there for visiting because
he was with Jackson Winkle John they had
a falling out so he left and then I
think he was doing stuff out of his
garage but then now he was downstairs
trading either with them now too I think
I'm not sure if he's doing his full Camp
there but I know he was doing some stuff
there one thing he's done right is put
that weight on slowly yeah that's the
one thing he's done right because he's
got accustomed to being 255 pounds and
walking around real big and heavy and he
looks real big and heavy he looks like a
heavyweight he doesn't look like a light
heavyweight they gained weight yeah he
looks like a [ __ ] heavyweight and I
wonder who he's sparring with because
you know there's this
being in the gym and being who you are
Jon Jones you know there's people like
want to see how he is and a million
people are trying to get an inside scoop
of oh how does he look how does he look
and we really haven't heard anything
like that yeah from uh any other little
uh Birds on somebody's shoulder or
something like that so I'm wondering if
he's actually sparring with anybody
training with anybody or if he just has
that much loyal teammates that are not
going to say a word about it until he
wants to I don't know it's a good
question because if he's gonna fight a
guy like Cyril gone he really wants to
get some movement some some really Top
Flight kickboxers so like who does he
have that he can work with like that you
know you really want because Cyril is so
good at mixing up the kicks in the knees
and the punches and the combinations and
he's so and he's so light like the way
he stands on the outside like if you're
gonna compete against a guy like that
you got to get some similar looks and
how many similar looks are there out
there for a guy that's 245 pounds that
could move like that like it moves like
zero yeah there's not a lot yeah
interesting fight but here's the problem
let's say John beats zero gone okay
and then John fights Stipe and John
beats Depot then what
people are sleeping like Curtis blades I
think he's one of the toughest guys
there
my immediate goal is to beat Cyril gone
and to beat Stevie miocic Jon Jones said
after that will be in conversations with
the UFC go to the UFC heavyweight
um rankings
because I'm I'll show you what I'm
[ __ ] interested in
what I'm interested in at UFC
heavyweight click on that [ __ ]
oh my God that's the boy yeah Sergey
pavlovich that [ __ ] that's the
Russian Fedor
I mean the Russian Francis rather he
like comes out guns blazing on people
just like Francis used to that
[ __ ] can bomb he's a mod and
he's so fast too with that he's so
accurate very good does it have any
fights of his
okay not the way I have it
um the way he beat black beast and uh
tied to a boxer so quick
was incredible I mean we think about
Cyril gone going through that war with
him and Sergey just put it on him he's
his boxing is [ __ ] tight very tight
man real power punches excellent
technique big guy too yeah big heavy
[ __ ] I think Corey was talking about he
used to train with him and he was like
yeah we've been in a practice room with
us uh all the time and stuff like that
so coming up with here he is man I mean
this [ __ ] dude's scary I mean to beat
Derrick Lewis like that to have Derek
completely understand I mean look at the
combinations he's Landing
Mark Smith as well there's a Dan Murphy
I'd have seen enough look at that that
[ __ ] dude can crack
he can crash he's interesting so I want
to see him fight more obviously he beat
two go to the tie two evasive he beat
two ivassa I mean the [ __ ]
combinations this guy has
look at this boom Oh that was so smooth
30 seconds and Ty gets up and just guns
blazing
so accurate
enjoying it oh my goodness
dude
so he's to me out of with Francis
leaving he's one of the most interesting
guys at heavyweight if not the most
interesting guy at heavyweight yeah I'm
very interested to see him fight a guy
like Jon Jones that that's crazy to me
so if John gets a few fights at
heavyweight if he gets zero gone if he
beats him that's enough and then if he
beats deep in the ocean that's another
if and then he fights surgery